bitcoin and politicians there's lots of
folks who uh their main question is just
like what do the politicians think and
that's a loaded question because there's
you know multiple uh sides to the aisle
there are
various causes or specific aspects that
people care about but just give us your
kind of general sense of bitcoin and how
you're thinking about it today
well first of all in american politics
abraham lincoln said public sentiment is
everything and here's the reality there
are uh over 40 million people now uh who
own uh bitcoin or crypto bitcoin
obviously being
the biggest one and so it's something
that politicians can't ignore i mean
there are young staffers in everyone's
district who have uh wallets uh who are
on the exchanges or who have uh
non-custodial wallets and this is
something that even if they don't know
it uh their staff is saying hey this is
happening it's happening in everyone's
uh district so i think it's
the the opinion is changing uh from
a concern and a reflexive uh opposition
uh to now something more akin to okay
this is happening we have to learn about
it and then you have people uh like me
and ron wyden on the democratic side and
others on the uh republican side who say
actually you know there's nothing to be
afraid of this is a good thing this
means that we are democratizing access
to finance this means more people are
getting to uh participate uh in creation
of value and that we should be for uh
blockchain and we should be for
bitcoin got it and so when you start to
think about this um we've seen a number
of uh i'll call them events uh over the
last maybe year and a half two years
where uh there was legislation put
forward and sometimes it came from
politicians themselves sometimes it came
from regulators uh but there was uh kind
of a drill that was run in the crypto
community and i think that they've kind
of uh began to realize the seriousness
of this and and the importance of uh the
companies the individuals the leaders
participating in the political process
how much does that have an impact so
once one of these legislative bills are
up for vote and you or your colleagues
hear from
your constituents like
just talk a little bit as to kind of the
process of which that goes into forming
the opinion the votes that you take etc
it has a big impact uh this is a
community uh that is creating a lot of
jobs it's creating a lot of jobs
certainly in silicon valley and
spreading jobs in places like miami and
uh across the country and it is a
community that is creating economic
value
and it's a community like i said that is
creating a lot of excitement uh among a
lot of diverse communities i mean uh the
black uh community and latino community
are disproportionately represented in
owning a crypto so when we hear from the
larger community that there are things
that uh congress may be doing that are
unhelpful uh or uh that would squelch
innovation then we listen doesn't mean
that uh we always agree but we listen
let me tell you on the infrastructure
bill i would not have known if it
weren't from hearing from many many of
my constituents and many people that
there was a provision that was overbroad
and that was actually
going to negatively affect those engaged
in mining with nothing to do with
selling uh crypto or that was actually
going to uh it affect people who are
just for software
coders and so that to me was helpful and
it allowed me to have a conversation
with sarah weining and others saying
look we have to fix this
so political engagement participation
makes an enormous difference
particularly in an area where many
members of congress don't have that much
knowledge one of the things i've said is
i i went
and i i don't trade or own more than 10
bucks of crypto but i opened up a wallet
i actually went on
uh on on uh coinbase to see what what is
all this about i i said well what is
metamask and what does it mean to have
uh a a wallet that can have ethereum
partly i just think more members of
congress should just
do some of this so they get the
experience of what uh what it's like hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time